we are in the midst of a public health
crisis
i'm not talking about the china virus
i'm talking about a far more serious
threat
to public health liberal feminists
freaking out in their cars
and then for some reason posting it on
the internet this is a real
issue and it must be addressed so my
producer has assembled some of the most
extreme cases
for me to review and diagnose since i am
an expert scientist
before we start i would like to mention
that this video is sponsored by the book
orange man bad by zebra jones more on
that
later first let's roll the tape i was
just on the 405
and i got stuck in that stupid trump
rally
and they [ __ ] boxed me in and they're
pointing at me
and laughing at me saying ha ha really
that's what makes america great that's
up i could have [ __ ] died right now
that was so [ __ ] dangerous
pointing at me and laughing at a mexican
oh god that was really scary
so the most dangerous thing that she is
describing right now would seem to be
how she's driving and
filming this video because she looks
fine she looks okay
i also love that after what six eight
months of leftists burning down cities
and killing conservatives in the streets
that she's like well i'm i was in a
parade and this is dangerous people
shouldn't be doing this on the freeway
say well what about all those other
times i don't know those
actually resulted in violence and
injuries and death and you look
absolutely
fine lady this woman's actually
apparently an actress her name is
francia reza
she's been an actress for about 15 years
or so she's she's in a grown-ish
spin-off i don't know what any of these
words mean she's
so i guess there's a show called
grown-ish i guess that's the spin-off of
another series called black-ish
okay she's friends with selena gomez she
seems like she's doing okay
and she doesn't seem like she's been
victimized fortunately we we have
actual video of the trump parade that
she's describing
this video was taken by errol webber who
i guess is running for congress
in karen bass's district karen bass is
that communist who's currently
repping the district she runs the
congressional black caucus so this guy
errol weber
filmed the trump rally was this this
dastardly
dangerous scary rally that francia
raises describing
let's take a look earl weber here
republican for congress in the 37th
district and we are
driving along the 405 freeway turn this
back around
there we go and we are having a trump
car parade
here we go there we go
all right and then here's the trump
train at the front
i want you guys to see this look at this
look at this looks pretty safe to me
looks like a normal day on the freeway
except
some of the cars have american flags and
that's what scared this woman
raise a franchise in the way she was
describing i thought they would be all
really tightly packed it'd be on a
city street and they'd all be looking at
her and you know menacing and
sharpening their knives and you know
loading their guns no
just people are driving and she has
trump flags
american flags because no not the red
white and blue no get that away from me
people are in the midst not just of a
political crisis i think this is an
actual psychological crisis because they
can't make sense
of of the politics you know what they do
is they basically said trump is hitler
they can't explain what trump has done
that's particularly hitler-esque
they just say orange man bad orange man
bad is
also now a great children's book it's by
zephyr joan
great book to read to your child and
just explain to your child
all all that is going on in our world
really prepare them to
enter into our politics the book was
self-published it features hilarious
illustrations
along with witty retellings of the
orange man's first
term in office uh it's really terrific i
love this thing i'm going to be giving
this out to
friends of mine with kids for other
great political themed items check out
jones merch store which is
linked below and be sure to get your
copy of
orange man bad a very important stocking
stuffer but you get it even before then
it's an important gift
to help educate the next generation you
can go get it at amazon
or you can press the link in the
description okay
now back to my role my job as an expert
scientist diagnosing the public health
crisis
let's get back to the hysterical
feminists
oh really let this man burn you down
again look again when he deserved it
more than anyone
holy [ __ ] sh you guys
i'm driving your car but i just got a
notification that ruth bader ginsburg
died
this can't be real this one can't be
real could this year get anything
ruth you just had to make it to 2021.
why can't women have abortions
i just saw a [ __ ] pro-life side
driving down the [ __ ] road i mean a
visual breakdown
and i just wanna say all you people are
so fearful can you understand a single
[Applause]
word
i heard abortion stop bringing these
kids into horrible homes just because
you're broke
you're [ __ ] stupid and i wish i had
been aborted
on paper i am like a conservative
republican's worst
nightmare i am a pansexual polyamorous
non-binary no you're not
vegan you're not those aren't real
those aren't things you are [ __ ]
garbage are you on drugs
no i don't have to be on drugs i'm
smarter than you
on your best day you piece
yeah i got this you are sick who are you
i'm from california you should go back
so embarrassing i have to smoke anything
to be
stupid i don't want to vote for biden it
feels like voting for a republican
but i'm gonna do it you wanna know why
because the alternative is a [ __ ]
fascist
a fascist is a fascist maybe we can have
the conversation
about dismantling the two-party system
when a fascist
isn't running maybe we can do that later
kiddo champ chief
maybe we can talk about it later
that was the most articulate one at the
end i am willing to render my diagnosis
i think that all of these ladies
are suffering from a severe case of
empowerment this is empowerment right
this is what we were told
we've been told this for 50 60 years now
it's empowerment for women to go
out and support abortion and uh you know
sort of be on their own as atomized
individuals totally separated from the
world and even reality
in the case of the pansexual lady or
whatever she said that she was
actually maybe that wasn't so empowering
there have been all these surveys so you
take them with a grain of salt because
these social scientific surveys are just
often politicized in nonsense but
there have been many many of these
measuring happiness and they've found
that since the sexual revolution since
the second wave of feminism
women's happiness has declined both
relative to men
and in absolute terms so they've
absolutely gotten less happy
but also and it's no surprise that free
love would
would benefit men's pleasure centers
better than it would
women's also in relative terms they've
gotten less happy and now you have these
hysterical breakdowns here we're told
by the left that the past was very
oppressive the family was very
oppressive
traditional standards and mores very
oppressive and you have to liberate
yourself from that that way you can be
truly free
do those ladies seem liberated to you do
they seem truly free i remember lucille
ball
very very powerful strong woman she was
one time asked about women's lib
about you know sort of second wave
feminism all these movements and she
said i feel liberated enough i feel a
little too liberated actually
i think i want to be a little less
liberated if that's a liberation
man maybe maybe we should rethink that
whole liberation thing maybe we should
consider returning
to traditional standards or this
epidemic
is only going to get worse and this is
going to cause a public health crisis
for me because
it blew out my eardrum i hope you get
better ladies
you